[Musique]
à
oui
salut les terriens
dans votre top du samedi soir bonsoir
rené therrien invité ce soir celui qui
ne veut pas dire qu'il fume du shit des
qui vient dans cette émission dès qu'il
en a plus daniel houghton
autre terrienne a invité ce soir madame
la comtesse de la tour-du-pin chambly de
la chasse
charles pascal rien quand on est enfant
votre nom c'est van damme à trois
organes
et younes et bambi
[Applaudissements]
les humoristes qui font le buzz un juif
à la rade un duo explosif
en p3b les atouts et ses conclusions
nous accueillerons notre teria du samedi
20 heures ce soir
une surprise pour vous daniel je vous en
dis pas plus voilà l'émission s'appelle
salut les terriens le groupe les
gréement de fortune
[Musique]
et
maintenant j'accueille mon stagiaire tom
villa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
t'a piqué le semblant de daniel bah oui
tu apparente mais non j'ai pas honte
tina turner s'est très bien maintenant
mais on lui mettra le grand baddou et
puis voilà
petit débrief démission de la semaine
dernière la sur les réseaux sociaux les
gens trouvent que vous avez encore fait
du holland machine y aille thierry je
vous avais dit je sais j'y arrive pas on
va écouter je vous ai fait une fille je
pourrais c'est dire du bien de françois
hollande a essayé on a fait un truc si
il est gentil et il mange bien la
cantine non non c'est le non non non ça
c'est pour mon neveu pendant longtemps
pour moi
il est gentil voila voila
ca ses moeurs
quel plateau ce soir thierry daniel
auteuil daniel l'un de nos plus grands
acteurs en france alors à vos débuts
vous avez joué un ado qui passaient le
bac dans les sous doués 1 alors vous
aviez 29 ans et tout le monde ya cru
voilà bon en même temps comme j'ai lu
que vous aviez redoublé 3 fois votre
quatrième en fait le bac à 29 ans était
pas un film c'était un documentaire
alors on est obligé d'en parler voilà où
on vous avait proposé bienvenue chez les
ch'tis est intouchable et finalement ça
s'est pas fait de films 40 millions de
spectateurs c'est pas grave voilà c'est
pas long mais c'est pas grave il pouvait
pas
laisser tout ça dans le cinéma regarder
coluche et jacques villeret a dû jouer
ugolin et finalement ça s'est passé une
chose
mickey rourke avait refusé le flic de
beverly hills richard geere piège de
cristal passe-partout game of thrones
donc ça arrive
daniel auteuil en ce moment vous mettez
en scène et vous jouer dans la pièce
l'envers du décor où les pensées secret
des personnages double les vrais
dialogues et ça je trouve que c'est une
excellente idée voilà je voudrais sont
même si c'est de la merde je peux lui
dire non je vraiment j'ai adoré la pièce
moi je n'ai même pas vu ward qui rime il
s'en fout et puis je trouve que c'est
très bien vu voilà votre duo avec
valérie bonneton fonctionne à merveille
sinon
profit de la situation il va le
regretter et du personnellement
[Applaudissements]
n
lyonnaise ces bandits l'arabe et le juif
alors juste avant de commencer dit toi
qui est le juif qui est le polygame
lui c'est moi je suis l'arabe et moi
c'est le coproducteur alors juste avant
le spectacle s'appelle arabes et les
juifs mais vous avez retiré le titre de
la fiche moi j'ai un nouveau titre à
vous proposer me cacher me halal mais
100% circoncis
[Musique]
pascal de la tour du pin le meilleur
pour la fin à l'instar de bfm tv serait
facile mais si vous faites la matinale
vos rivaux le matin c'est william
leymergie et les lapins crétins
janvier 2015 bfmtv bat son record
d'audience à cause des attentats dans la
bfm tv la chaîne qui va bien quand la
france va mal non mais moi ce que j'aime
beaucoup sur bfm tv c'est les
témoignages ce que quand il ya un drame
on shoppe toujours celui qui est le plus
près de la situation le voisin et le
voisin il a toujours la même phrase bah
écoutez je suis extrêmement surpris
vraiment je m'y attendais pas du tout
alors pour nous c'était quelqu'un de
sympathique il allait chercher des
gamins à l'école on nous disait bonjour
le matin non mais c'est vrai en disant
de bfm tv on n'a jamais vu un mec dire
ah ouais [__] enfin ça fait trois ans
qu'ils les gorges des chats dans sa cave
il y avait pas et à vous qui l'aviez pas
vu comme ça
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs ici pour vous
poser les questions trop con que thierry
ardisson n'a pas voulu vous posez
pascal de la tour du pin alors vous êtes
la seconde matinale de tele2 france
juste derrière télématin c'est comment
d'être derrière william leymergie rider
non
moi tu vas te sortir de ces
daniel auteuil alors daniel pour votre
dernier mariage vous aviez choisi dave
comme témoin voilà c'était pour
l'empêcher de chanter à la cérémonie
il a chanté on peut pas laisser à la
pêcherie 30 élèves yuna ces bandits dans
le spectacle vous dresser un mur
imaginaire pour pour défendre votre
territoire de seine du coup c'est
comment ses 55 ans tous et comme en
palestine 70 30 non
[Applaudissements]
ces familles là notre stage rentrées
d'ici la semaine prochaine et d'ici là
au théâtre apollo
voilà il triomphe au théâtre il cartonne
au cinéma ni au top c'est daniel auteuil
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
daniel auteuil rebond soir très heureux
de vous recevoir ce soir je suis fan de
vous voici ici j'ai tout vos disques
heureusement une avec ah oui elle avait
deux alors daniels a l'air très heureux
en ce moment vous êtes amoureux écoutez
les amis papa oui vous êtes l'un des
derniers grands acteurs français
dambielle a plane jeunes qui arrivent à
regarder sur tous les 6 mois 2 ne sais
pas c'est pas stressant tout ce bonheur
écoutez n'ont cessé ces deux il faut il
faut l'apprécier avec lucidité je le
suis et j'en profite nous sommes lucides
et raisonnée alors la dernière fois
qu'il est venu ici c'était pour le film
entre amis d'olivier baroux votre
personnage sortait avec une femme
beaucoup plus jeune que lui voilà
aujourd'hui dans la pièce qui vous amène
l'envers du décor de florian zeller
c'est votre meilleure amie qui sort avec
une femme beaucoup plus jeune que lui
vous avez pas marre qu'on utilise votre
vie privée pour trouver l'inspiration
daniel frais non non c'est ça m'aide si
vous voulez comme ça j'ai pas à forcer
la nation j'ai toujours juste c'est un
admet secret quoi c'est ça c est l 2 ans
la pièce donc elle triomphe actuellement
au théâtre de paris révèle l'envers du
décor dont vous êtes marié avec valérie
bonneton et un soir vous inviter l'un de
vos amis françois eric gendron qui vient
de quitter sa femme pour une plus jeune
qui est interprété par pauline lefèvre
résultat rien ne se passe comme prévu ça
part en vrille et moi c'est un c'est un
dîner pathétique qui va se passer moi je
vais tout de suite projetés sur cette
belle fille et
imaginer que je pars avec elle au
mexique que chacun de ces regards c'est
une provocation de sa part alors
justement il ya des monologues en plus
de dialogue
ces apartés enfin oui si ça c'est à dire
que la pièce met en scène deux niveaux
de langage le langage par les courants
et la pensée ce qui est marrant c'est
qu'au bout d'un moment la pensée la
parole normal ce mais ce mélange la
science au spectacle tout le temps j
comprennent très vite le principe à
partir du moment où on dit des horreurs
ils savent qu'on est dans la pensée
parce que
on est bien élevé encore quand pauline
lefèvre arrive votre femme bonneton dit
tu cherchais une [__] et sa part
maintenant et vous vous dites mais de
quelle couleur et sasha quand je dis pas
ça comment de façon plus élégante je la
regardais jeudi jeudi c'est étrange ses
sourcils sont légèrement plus sombre que
ses cheveux après j'ai dit oui c'est ses
cheveux ses cheveux ne sont pas de la
même couleur que ses sourcils et après
en déduction jeudi mais de quelle
couleur et sasha
alors la pièce a été écrite pour vous en
la lisant vous avez décidé de la mettre
en scène ouais c'est la deuxième fois
vous faites une mise en scène après
t'empêches tout le monde de dormir en
1981 mais bon il ya prescription de
celle là non c'est vachement bien je
conseille à tout le monde d'avoir
qu'est-ce que je peux faire de plus non
mais ça va aller tout se passe bien
vraiment merci j'ai vu les gens là alors
[Applaudissements]
ensuite il ya deux films à venir donc il
ya les naufragés le 17 février ces
comédies familiales comme ça de deux
types qui font naufrage sur une île
déserte ils vont te crever sans
s'apercevoir que derrière et un hôtel
cinq étoiles voilà donc c'est humain et
puis a au nom de ma fille là c'est autre
chose ce 16 mars ces histoires de
bamberski le mec qui a passé sa vie à
essayer de faire condamner et l'assassin
présumé de sa fille c'est pas c'est pas
pour nous c'est pas une histoire de
vengeance mais je me dis que ce type a
passé trente ans pour faire en sorte que
sa fille soit toujours vivante c'est un
cetain je pense que c'est un de mes plus
beaux rôles ou sinon je pense mon art
celui-ci bamberski sonnerie voulait
incroyable
[Musique]
daniel
vous dit
le temps glisse de plus en plus vite
vite la vie ça dure cinq minutes on se
retourne et c'est déjà fini c'est un
truc qui passe très vite surtout quand
on a la chance qu'elle soit comme une
opérette aussi joyeuse et gaie comme les
opérettes que chanter vos parents voilà
c'est ça vous dit je comprends ce que
veut dire mon père quand il disait
profite profite oui il me dit je
comprenais pas et des profits très bon
fils profite mais je je je profite c'est
déjà tellement
de quoi papa de qualcomm c'est et il
avait raison que c'est si jamais assez
vous dites aujourd'hui je veux vivre en
état d'urgence maintenant les années
contre uc triple oui j'ai la chance
d'avoir pu décrocher un un autre tour
nul t-il tour de manège magnifique avec
cette jeune femme avec ce ce jeune
enfant
j'ai vécu très heureux avec mes autres
enfants et etc c'est quelque chose c'est
quelque chose de rare oui oui je profite
c'est ma priorité vous vous dites quand
je me vois dans la glace avec mairie de
mes cheveux gris je dis bonjour monsieur
mais dans ma tête j'ai toujours
l'impression d'avoir 20 ans c'est vrai
vous verrez s'inquiéter rigoureux et
vous étirer le sais mais bon en même
temps j'ai j'ai pas 85 ans à je veux
dire
et puis à aude
vert
douze ans avec haut de 12 ans 12 ans à
faire semblant de savoir utiliser un
iphone 12 ans à rentrer le ventre faut
bien le dire
c'est difficile oui c'est difficile
c'est sûr tous et tous ces trucs moderne
doit cesser ses boutons
effectivement ça assez c'est utile vous
êtes déclaré dans gala
l'amour c'est tellement beau je dis ça
vu ça je me suis crevée là
j'ai dit ça vous avez dit s'inspirer
alors je vais vous dire quand on est
capable de trouver normal de dire une
phrase aussi concours c'est tellement
beau celle qu'on est vraiment un mot oui
j'ai dit j'ai dit ça c'est ingénieux et
moi j'assume je
dois dire la même chose christiane mieux
à part l'argent
voilà c'est une heure
on se retrouve bien après
[Musique]
heureusement soir les kayaks non sur les
talons de votre temps toujours en
compagnie de daniel auteuil
le pascal de la tour-du-pin
combiner ces bandits
or daniel bien trucs que les gens savent
pas en fait c'est qu'on s'est connus
adolescents avignon et nous nous sommes
croisés dans la rue de l'oriflamme on y
retourne allez on y va
[Musique]
c'est chaud hot chicken il fait chaud
comme on n'est pas bien à l'arrêt très
bien il fait un peu chaud heureusement
koné à londres tu entends les cigares ah
oui à la fois un bruit assourdissant
là me fatigue le bruit de l'eau tu
l'entends olala oui ça me tape dans la
tête et le bruit de l'eau qui coule dans
le pastis tu as celui là ils me
réveillent
ça fait plaisir de te voir c'est bien
parce qu'on n'est pas dans les clichés
qu'est ce que tu aimes ou que tu en veux
la lumière j'aime la lumière et les
souvenirs qui remontent à l'appel bien
entendu mais la lumière est quelque
chose de
quelqu'un qui qui fut
dix mois
- daniel dubois des mois
merci beaucoup les femmes de ta vie et
je dois dire quand j'allume ma pipe
quelques-unes
quelques unes mais tu sais avec le temps
on oublie
en fait aujourd'hui tous nos pitchouns
et oui j'ai cette chasse aux vilains et
qui a de belles vaches bien rhône qui
m'a fait un bel enfin c'est qui cette
petite cette petite le s'appelle aude
des jeunes elle et elle n'est pas
vieille
elle a l'âge légal un palais en prison
tiens la santé ou grâce à vous il
vaut mieux mais le petit rat le petit
c'est un amour l'oct appelle papa ou pas
p et ils m'appellent mon vieux
je crois qu'il sera prêt dans aqua de
toi moi je crois qu on se rappellera des
sous-doués
pendant une vingtaine d'années on se
rappellera aussi un peu de jean de
florette et que j'étais un gars plutôt
sympathiques comme les biens l'aimé bien
lui a il est mort à bord
justement le jour tu testes gaga sera
qu'est ce que tu veux comme disait de
toi c'est pas prévu par les
foules ya des trucs de fitch fait partie
de ma mort je peux mourir la touffeur à
oui mais malheureux en même temps ça
peut la faire partir mais pendant le
commerçant s'est passé dans ce qui me
met mal à l'aise
tu es riche aujourd'hui tchad et sous
gdes ou non jeu ça va le pas mauvais non
ça va ça va mais je suis pas riche riche
alors si j'étais riche riche je serai
pas là
tu joues toujours au théâtre le soir ah
oui ça m'arrive
toujours au théâtre et le conte thèmes
comme tu applaudis sur toi j'aime ça
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
et maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pascal de la tour-du-pin rebond soit
sept journalistes vous présenter avec
christophe de les premières éditions la
matinale de bfm tv plus le vendredi soir
l'histoire en direct et vous êtes la
première comtesse a présenté le journal
télévisé
[Musique]
vous êtes la comtesse des matinales
c'est déjà ça ça a été le carrosse sur
le perez a été difficile mais ça prend
du temps alors l'histoire est magnifique
en fait vous appelez pascal gaillard
vous étiez employée comme femme de
ménage par la duchesse
de la tour chambly de la chasse est un
jour la duchesse donne un grand bal dans
son château là des souris mus habile
elle nous habille ses souris en
princesse et vous séduisez lecomte un
fils de la duchesse à minuit vous
dépêcher de rentrer chez vous avant que
le carrosse de se transforme en
citrouille heureusement vous oubliez
votre soulier et c'est comme ça que le
compte vous retrouve et vous épouser
mois
[Applaudissements]
en fait votre père et bâtonnier le
bâtonnier pierre gaillard la mission à
bon et votre mère isabelle et juristes
et elle s'occupait d'un théâtre
enseigner l'art mais moi je sais tout il
faut se méfier avec moi à 7 alors voilà
conteuse pascale de la tour-du-pin
chambly la charge c'est injuste le nom
via l'adresse de danse
voilà alors le plus dingue c'est que
l'ancêtre de votre mari albert de cire
de la tour du pin a participé à la
troisième croisade contre les musulmans
je me disais bien que ça vient
est ce que quand vous partez de chez
vous il vous met une ceinture de
chasteté leveaux n'est bien sûr qu'une
couronne sur la terre avant d'arriver
voiliers de l'alcool alors la gueule de
votre mari a été guillotiné pendant la
révolution française si tu peux qui sont
arrivés wiimote mais qui fait la gueule
le 14 juillet
alors j'ai remarqué quand même qu'à
bfmtv c'est incroyable et apolline de
malherbe margot de frouville karine de
mai non ville
de
recrutement nous blesse
quand même si c'est un peu alors je me
mets dedans oncle et la matinale de bfm
tv avec christophe de l'est entre 6
heures et 8 heures et demie c'est bien
vous lever à 1h30 tous les jours il faut
le savoir et vous fait un score
incroyable sur la tranche des français
en pyjama qu'on va peut-être donc
c'est maintenant
vous n'êtes pas loin sont sagement sur
les 15 49 vous n'êtes pas loin de france
2 oui effectivement on fait que 3
millions cumulés quand même le matin
deuxième chaîne de france donc c'est une
belle c'est une belle aventure vous avez
une voix formidable c'est quand même pas
que les clubs par jonathan vois pas quoi
moi adacore là c'est beaucoup
christophe de laisser mans vous vous me
tutoyez alors que vous vous voyez
monsieur le comte j'imagine oui bien sûr
nous voyons c'est sûr c'est plus simple
et on se tutoie long terme on est assez
naturel c'est bientôt le 2 ça fonctionne
très bien sans vraiment vous aime bien
alors la matinale de bfm tv c'est très
cool un pouvoir ils se font maquiller en
plateau par exemple c'est pas comme
ailleurs c'est pas comme les autres
chaînes
effectivement et alors ce qui est cool
aussi chez bfm tv c'est les bandeaux de
bave écran assez extraordinaire voilà
christiane président des états unis
il ya le train aussi les trains qui vont
à 1200 km par seconde c'est quand même
c'est comme ça j'aime cette chaîne parce
que t'as pas besoin de fumer des pétards
c'est une joie surréalistes il ya le
survivant du ps aussi
comment ça se fait ça c'est à dire ils
sont pas réveillés non
effectivement deux escrocs l'anc est
derrière et qui attaquent ces bandeaux
parfois ça peut être des erreurs
informatiques aussi marqué alors je vais
dire à votre décharge que c'est pareil
sur i télé sur lci
mais il ya mieux enfin pire
quatre heures de déplacement car je
ferai donc ce drame écrit le talent
violent je pense que trestman à venir au
cirque service
dollé hu allait elle n est pas bonne est
sorti dans les points ce soir elle et
son attention démonter ville
et moi
c'est une nouvelle tendance c'est vrai
pas lourd ça cartonne à l'élan c'est
beaucoup de travail et plus productif m
je vous félicite
est ce que le coût de la boîte de nuit
championnat taux de la matinale
franchement c'est bien non c'est vrai
dans le genre j'ai fait plein de
conneries celle là je la trouve bien
merci alors on a beaucoup critiqué bfm
tv pour la couverture des attentats
contre charlie hebdo la prise d'otage
des frères couach il attaque du musée du
bardo à tunis
évidemment une chaîne d'info qui se
comporteraient bien ça de notre journal
de 20 heures donc ça serait pas
intéressant mais on a commis des erreurs
on les a reconnu les erreurs et je lui
il ya eu des erreurs qui ont été
commises
effectivement c'est ses 20 secondes sur
des heures et des heures d'antenne et
puis on a été extrêmement vigilant parce
que dans la dernière séquence
malheureusement que nous avons vécue
lors des attentats du 13 novembre nous
avons été extrêmement vigilant de
rapporter les faits si vous voulez on
avait vraiment cette épée de damoclès
sur la tête était hors de question de
répéter une telle erreur j'ai remarqué
vous avez découvert le conditionnel
alors on essaie
le conditionnel on essaie surtout de
rapporter les faits c'est à dire que
d'éviter de spéculer sur sur les
événements qui se passent notamment sur
sur la soude saint denis on a été très
très factuelle j'ai vu lorsque manche
chaîne d'info c'est que la règle et à
l'eau qu'est ce qui se passe je dis j'en
sais rien et encore maintenant il ya des
images mais je me souviens c'est un
événement dramatique et la première
guerre du golfe il n'y avait aucune
image avec parlé toute la nuit les
hommes du rang parlé toute la nuit pour
ne rien dire et sans rien alors c'est
vrai il faut savoir aussi que la
personne qui vient sur bfm tv elle reste
pas deux heures à nous regarder
à nous ça nous donne l'heure
alors on va voir si vous aimez vraiment
jean-philippe oui le compte de la
tour-du-pin chandy de la chasse
évidemment on va faire une interview par
amour
[Musique]
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
arrêter la tv je suis je suis pas sûr
parce que la personne qui même nous ne
demandera pas d'arrêter la télé c'est ma
passion est-ce que par amour pourriez
vous convertir à une autre religion
ma carte
la question s'est pas posée par amour
vous pourriez avoir recours à la
chirurgie esthétique
la chirurgie esthétique alors le mec qui
me demande
qui dégage tout de suite vous le dis
est ce que par amour / y est prête à
arrêter de fumer
la question a été posée certains fument
j'en finis bas il fait mais il faisait
pas bien s'est arrêtée mais s'arrête ce
n'est pas vous c'est un gros défaut
c'est un gros plaisir aussi
si commettez un crime jan filc imaginons
les commettent un crime vous seriez
prête à lui fournir un alibi à vous
dénoncez à sa place ou attendre 20 ans
qui sortent de prison
il fournit un alibi peut-être vingt ans
c'est
encore mieux c'est comme les croisades
alors vous apprenez que vous avez une
rivale il me dit un soir jean philippe
en larmes est ce que vous serez capable
de partager
de pardonner et le tue
de pardonner
ça va mieux mais
c'est pas vrai est ce que vous seriez
prête à accepter qu'il ait une maîtresse
non je vois pas l'om attendait un
jeu bien tard donné mais
est ce que vous seriez prête allait tous
les soirs dans des clubs échangistes
avec lui s'il vous le demande et non
cotées ça je crois pas je me lavais 1h30
comment
alors dernière question et non la
moindre est ce que vous seriez prête
à devenir son esclave sexuelle
sa chose non j'ai pas trop de mentalité
d'esclave non c'est pas bon non mais
c'est un jeu amoureux à st gelais mois
enfin du jeu c'est sympa
pauvre jean philippe
[Musique]
et maintenant mesdames messieurs am
arabe et un juif ensemble sur scène si
younès et banlieue
[Musique]
younes s'ébaubir bonsoir fois
c'est marrant quand je dis mais ces
bandits j'ai l'impression que le mariage
gay
ce qui nous lie beaucoup mais pas du
tout
bien sûr quatre fils et quatre du café
on le mettait dans ce spectacle c'est
bien
[Musique]
alors après foot it et chocolat laurel
et hardy omar et fred eric et ramzy
kadéos elie et dieudonné et jackie et
michel voici le nouveau duo comique qui
monte younes et bambi mesdames messieurs
ils sont forts
[Musique]
ils auraient pu s'appeler les frères
ennemis mais c'était déjà pris alors
vous monter ensemble sur scène pour
dénoncer les préjugés
islamophobes et antisémites vous saluer
le public en disant shalom alikoum est
ce que vous dites aussi il ya là akbar
khan comme ça je peux mourir
alors barbie quand vous entendez allah
est grand vous dites quoi c'est pas
grave on va lui trouver sa taille
alors pour la fiche paraît que ça pas
été facile il voulait toute la place je
vais laisser 30%
et vous achetez des cailloux n'ont
jamais et sur la loge de la rouge est
mis d'accord bailat 4 nages en est une
ça change pas quoi comme démissionner
alors younès arbouge à vous êtes né le
29 mars 1987 châteauroux comme michel
denisot et gérard depardieu c'est bien
ce n'est pas rien vous avez grandi là
bas j'ai grandi à châteauroux votre père
était ouvrier votre mère femme au foyer
vous avez commencé le théâtre à 16 ans
et à 20 ans vous monter à paris vous
êtes surveillante dans un lycée c'est
dingue qu'on vous donne les élèves à
garder quand même hein moi aussi je déjà
revenons pas à me gérer moi-même ouais
c'est ça bambi alors au départ je
croyais que bambi c'était une version en
cours de bambis bergues
looberghe maintenant c'est samuel jean
et bonbis et en hommage à michael
jackson c'est ça exactement les
pédophiles
culture
alors dans chaque interview vous donnait
une version différente de votre
rencontre
qu'est ce qu'ils doivent aux filles j'ai
dit aux gars la piscine la scène et la
tôle non non on s'est rencontré dans une
rue
château un château précisément à
montgivray moi je pensais que vous étiez
connu on a une partie de frisbee avec
une kippa
[Musique]
ensuite j'ai été repéré par djamel vous
avez jamel comedy club bon on y est
aujourd'hui ouais ça c'est bien bah
c'est la meilleure le meilleur centre de
formation pour des humoristes désaccord
c'est lui toulouse ac a cru en nous en
premier donc ok voilà on le remercie
alors sur scène vous parlez de tout le
conflit israélo-palestinien allons
septembre la shoah les quenelles partiel
que j'adore c'est on peut faire des
blagues sur les juifs non c'est de
l'antisémitisme et sur les musulmans
abaisse ainsi la liberté d'expression
c'est un malheureusement c'est un peu
vrai une grande partie de la population
lorsque l'on ressent comme ce à quoi on
ressent comme ça on a l'impression que
c'est plus facile de taper sur sept une
certaine catégorie de personnes donc
c'est pour ça qu'on a fait c'est vrai
[Musique]
vous ne serez pas étonné qu'on vous
fasse une interview l'arabe ou le chf
[Musique]
qui est le chef la boucle juifs bat bien
et vivent pas dans un duo c'est pas
possible qu'il y ait deux chefs c'est
vrai que moi
qui est le plus intelligent la boule
juifs
quand rien qu historiquement on a des
cerveaux chez nous einstein freud marx
samatan ça c'est des juifs d'europe de
l'est ces ashkénaze et un jus du maghreb
séfarades en gros les ashkénazes
einstein et vous avez de ricoh macias
[Applaudissements]
qui a le plus de problèmes avec sa
communauté après s'être lancé dans ce
spectacle dans chaque communauté chaque
dans ma communauté il ya il ya des cons
et dans la mène aussi à des combats y en
a un peu marre du sud
qui s'est un peu plus exploiter là où
j'ai
vu qu'on est produit par jamel c'est
l'arabe et le juif
qui a eu l'idée du spectacle à l'onu
nonu
d'ailleurs on embrasse ban ki-moon dans
son bain qui fait nos premières parties
[Applaudissements]
genève c'est bon merci d'avoir été avec
nous voilà c'était la paix que james
ltée on se voit près d'un tube avec le
japon quignon nôtres terriens du samedi
matin sur facebook
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vos romans sont l'éternel
bonsoir les terriens
l'autre suspect toujours en compagnie de
daniel auteuil
[Applaudissements]
le pascal de la tour du pin
et nous accueillons notre terriens du
samedi 20 heures pascal duquenne
accompagnée de sa mère huguette
[Applaudissements]
mais tu as des cheveux blancs
mais bon y'a pas ses mots
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir une guinguette bonsoir
pascal bonsoir alors il ya tout juste 20
ans daniel votre tandem avec pascal le
huitième jour faisait chavirer le coeur
des français un film pour lequel vous
avez décroché tous les deux le prix
d'interprétation au festival de cannes
ce soir je vous propose de rembobiner
votre incroyable histoire voilà dans un
instant stéphane guillon mais d'abord le
zapping
c'était le zapping jusqu'ici tout allait
bien mais voici stéphane guillon
[Applaudissements]
on commence avec une bonne nouvelle
alain finkielkraut reçu en séance
solennelle à l'académie française pour
l'occasion les immortels ont remis au
philosophe son habit vert et son épée
remettre une épée à finkielkraut
c'est pas très prudent
je tiens avant tout à remercier mes
pairs les 39 immortels de l'académie
française pour la confiance et l'honneur
qu'il me faut grâce à cette épée un
moment sa pierre je n'aurai de cesse de
défendre la langue de molière de
ferraille et transpercer porter
l'estocade occire
maltraitera l'orthographe brutalise ras
le verbe est rude voire à la grammaire
taisez vous
paraît que c'était une boucherie
nos académiciens
le livre de nicolas sarkozy continue à
caracoler en tête des ventes c'est fou
c'est fou le simple fait qu'ils nous
disent j'ai merdé je me suis trompé ça
nous surprend tellement qu'on l'achète
pour vérifier alors nous on y croit pas
quoi quel dommage qu'il n'ait pas été
chez laurent ruquier léa salamé
critiquant le livre de sarkozy serait un
grand moment
[Musique]
je suis partagé nicolas sarkozy sera
partagé vous je vous le dire je suis
partagé ou publié chez plon la france
pour la vie 300 pages de confession
d'autocritique on vous sent sincère vous
ne vous épargner pas le casse toi pauv'
con vous regrettez le yacht de bolloré
vous n'auriez pas dû y aller j'ai
abaissé la fonction présidentielle dit
vous c'est un mea culpa vous battez
votre couple c'est un livre qu'on ne
lâche pas c'est un souk jeu là vous j'ai
été pris c'est vous qui l'avez écrit on
reconnaît votre style il manque parfois
des mots ou alors elles sont à l'envers
je vous cite je vous si nicolas sarkozy
la souffrance est quelque chose que je
suis sensible on vous entend parler
c'est la réussite principal de ce j'ai
un bémol nicolas sarkozy j'ai un bémol
est ce que ce livre n'est pas une fois
de plus un plan com est-ce que et ce
sera ma question nicolas sarkozy est ce
que ce livre n'est pas un chant du cygne
votre dernière cartouche répondez moi
sincèrement nicole pour vous sans doute
et est-ce que vous doutez nicolas
sarkozy
je me demande qu'est-ce qui est le plus
fatiguant puis quelques routes ou
à venir faut pas qu'ils passent un
enfant tous les deux
on passe au reste de l'actualité
[Musique]
contrairement à ce qui a été dit les
terroristes du bataclan n'était pas
droguée au moment des faits bonne
nouvelle si la brigade anti terrorisme
n'a rien vu venir au moins les stups ont
fait leur boulot
[Rires]
sport à huit mois des jeux olympiques de
rio le virus zitka transmis par les
piqûres de moustiques inquiète le brésil
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
des jo aucune piqûre pourrait handicaper
am athlètes
[Applaudissements]
showbiz julien lepers va bientôt monter
sur scène eh bah voila voila voila on
vire quelqu'un qui faisait de mal à
personne
28 ans qui l'animé questions pour un
champion on était tranquille et
maintenant ils se vengent y monte sur
scène tant pis pour nous
[Applaudissements]
paris-match consacre quatre pages à
l'ancien ministre du budget jérôme
cahuzac juger la semaine prochaine pour
fraude fiscale et blanchiment
un reportage très émouvant sur ce banni
de la république ce proscrit qui tente
de survivre en jouant au golf et en
nageant le crawl en corse
l'acteur jean-pierre bacri toujours
sensible à l'injustice a souhaité réagir
franchement
ça me débecte moelleux tu vois ce genre
de reportage sur les états d'âme de
monsieur cahuzac eux les ouvriers de
goodyear qui ont pris neuf mois ferme
juste pour avoir séquestré leur patron
je pense pas qu'ils qui soignent leur
cafards en juin la balle et ils n'ont
même pas de quoi se se payer une balle
cc comme balkany cac a un casier
judiciaire long comme le bras qui
quelques toujours député ou et ça ça
me débecte voilà ce coussin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après l'italie qui a fait recouvrir des
statuts de nu la france a reçu le
président juan miro petit déjeuner car
celui ci ne voulait pas de bouteille de
vin sur la table fabrice luchini a
souhaité réagir
non mais tu imagines la soumission
l'armée au delà de ce que décrit
houellebecq on renonce aux vins sur la
table rohani contre bacchus pendant
qu'on y est fallait aussi recouvrir lac
de triomphe s'est totalement vaginale
l'arc de triomphe pareil pour
l'obélisque en même temps tu recouvre
l'obélisque que tu fais l'apologie de la
capote c'est pire que tout
la pyramide du louvre à la limite ça
passait encore roanne il est tellement
tordu tout d'un coup il va te dire que
c'est un plat ghana ap le canal qui
s'illumine dans la nuit satan dans toute
sa splendeur on touche le fond à la
semaine prochaine j'aurai reçu
[Applaudissements]
sur canal
et sur la scène
le chasser
et on passe maintenant à notre terriens
du samedi 20 heures
[Musique]
huguette et pascal re bonsoir
alors pascal vous êtes né le 8 août 1970
à vilvorde à 15 km de bruxelles perd
mécanographe à la sabena vous étiez
huguette institutrice en fait on vous
appelle mamy cacahuète vous adorez les
cacahuètes absolument c'est pour ça
alors à la naissance ce petit garçon aux
yeux [__] huguette vous le baptisé mon
petit chinois c'est vrai qu'à l'époque
ya pas de diagnostic prénatal
et deux mois plus tard vous tombé des
nues lorsque le médecin vous annonce
madame votre fils et mongolien j'ai pris
ça comme un budget
comme une gifle
ouais c'est à dire je ne sais pas très
bien ce que c'est à l'époque
alors deuxième coup dur votre mari ne
supporte pas la naissance de pascal et
deux ans a pris part
mais là pour relever la tête
et puis enrico aussi c'est vrai que
enrico votre deuxième mari s'occupe des
enfants comme si c'étaient ses propres
enfants mes respects
pour mieux comprendre pascal à l'âge de
40 ans vous décidez huguette retourner
sur les bancs de la faculté pour étudier
la psychologie et pendant ce temps
enrico toujours lui s'occupe des gosses
un mec bien chapeau 1 et chapeau vous
captez mieux ses sentiments dites vous
après ses études
ce écologie alors pascal à l'époque vous
tombez souvent malades entre 0 et 10 ans
vous ferez 25 séjour en clinique d'abord
il ya la sde et puis aussi vous êtes
très fragile c'est à dire qu'une piqûre
de moustique ou une piqûre de rose ça
peut déclencher chez vous une septicémie
donc c'est très compliqué évidemment
pour vous j'imagine
mais pascal vous ne vous laissez jamais
abattre quand vous êtes en clinique vous
danser sur les tables
vous chanter à tue tête avec votre tour
nos disques et votre micro vous voulez
être le chouchou or vous avez envie de
vous exprimer comme sa
mairie le chrétien comme ça à
l'adolescence vous laisser très libre
votre enfant vous traversez bruxelles à
vélo pour retrouver votre mère à l'école
près prenez des risques incroyable non
un jour vous passez sous un camion quand
même
métier drôlement inquiète très inquiète
quand je l' ai appris moi ce que je n'y
attache pas mais tout le monde vous dit
le gars tu t'es folle de lui laisser
autant de liberté et vous vous pensez
que c'est bien pour le développement de
pascal que voulu l'essayer faire tout ça
cette amérique qui le voulaient ma mort
je le ferai plus je n'aurai plus
d'accidents mais je veux faire comme
yves comme son grand frère
alors vous poussez pascal vers la
natation vers l'athlétisme vers la danse
dans la musique l'équitation le ski et
même le théâtre
ou fait du théâtre depuis votre plus
tendre enfance vous avez commencé très
jeune en un crescendo 13 ans mais à
saison pour la première fois vous jouez
devant 200 spectateurs
ça devient sérieux la mère est là
[Musique]
le destin dans la salle il y a la
première épouse de jaco van dormael
réalisateur belge oscarisé pour un court
métrage et vous voilà pris dans le film
toto le héros
gagnera une caméra d'or et un césar
dire que jaco van dormael il ya toujours
eu confiance en vous depuis le début
la connaît
ensuite c'est le huitième jour en labs
est inquiète quand quand il est choisi
pour la 8e journée
absolument j'ai trouvé le scénario trop
difficile pour pascal mais jacques on
disait j'aime en confiance d'avoir
confiance et vous pascal vous sentiez
bien de le faire
jamais eu peur parvient mais jacquot
n'avait pas peur parce qu'elle n'avait
pas peur daniel quand on vous a dit que
vous alliez jouer avec pascal est ce que
vous avez eu peur non j'ai pas eu peur
et vous parler du spectacle je suis allé
voir ce spectacle et
et j'ai été sidéré c'est à dire que
c'était sur scène c'était des des
acteurs géniaux tous géniaux lui se
détacher il avait quelque chose en plus
au moment du salut j'avais l'impression
que c'était johnny hallyday qui veut des
sales usa se prenait à pied mortel à
venir étaient là à s'éclater et ensuite
comme je suis allé dans la loge j'avais
l'impression d'entrer dans une loge
d'acteurs à part entière nous les
houches chacun disait comment j'étais ce
oui mais voilà c'est c'est dire que
c'est c'est un acteur génial
alors
ils vont trouver tous les deux sur le
plateau huitième jour alors au début
vous regardez un peu est-ce qui a brisé
la glace entre vous c'est une bataille
de boules de neige oui oui mais ce que
ce qu'ils étaient car les choses et
c'est arrivé qui c'est un acteur préféré
il disait toujours c'est gérard
depardieu
est sympathique
et ça le faisait beaucoup rire
la boule de neige oui boule de neige un
chez moi à la maison près en belgique
oui oui je suis j'ai une maison belgique
mais savais pas qu'on pouvait payer ses
efforts et ses impôts en belgique
le 20 mai 1996 c'est la remise des prix
du 49ème festival de cannes on regarde
[Musique]
le dow a été donnée après le décès de
daniel auteuil
ce cas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs du jury c'est
merci d'avoir supprimé la différence
c'est d'avoir fait de pascal un acteur à
part entière merci à tous
[Applaudissements]
oui
sentant monter les escaliers on se les
marches cela on se disait qu'on était
champion du monde
qu'est ce qu'on m'a dit
mon dieu que c'est bon
il guette c'est formidable pour vous
tout ce que vous avez donné à pascal
comment vous êtes occupé de lui la
visite y ait dans la sarthe est oui tout
à fait ans au real est heureux parce que
je crois que au début le producteur
avait peur on pouvait pas dire qu'il
était trisomique avant que ça se passe à
cannes je crois quand même qu'il y avait
certaines
réticences à le dévoiler directement
parce qu'au fond c'était la toute
première fois
qu'un acteur trisomique
participe à quelque chose de grandiose
quoi c'est extraordinaire et ça restera
toujours toujours toujours la preuve
c'est qu'on entend
le film vendôme elle a changé et qu'il
n'y avait pas à l'époque c'est le regard
sur les trisomiques c'est à dire que ça
ça complètement les mentalités ont
évolué sur après ce film alors le film
fera 3 8 millions d'entrées un succès
extraordinaire
pascal quand vous l'avez vu vous êtes
dit est ce que c'est vrai ce que c'est
pas vrai cette histoire est voulue a été
obligée de lui dire non c'est du cinéma
bah oui ça vous a bouleversé de voir le
film
il ya des scènes quand il regarde pas ce
qu'ils regardent avec ses copains encore
régulièrement le huitième jour et à des
scènes où il est encore toujours émue
fière aussi tellement beau film est là
pascal devenu une star tient que vous
accompagnez le film dans sa tournée
mondiale vous allez au japon vous
découvrez le sac et vous avez aux usa
aux yeux ça s'appelle un hindou la plage
de malibu alerte à malibu
non c'est sûr se baladent partout dans
le monde comme ça en avion on va danser
la nuit à chicago a travaillé dans les
boîtes de nuit on a des interviews comme
ça avec toute la presse aux etats unis à
los angeles
il y avait 50 journalistes et puis il ya
un journaliste qui lui demande alors
pascal comment êtes vous avec les
journalistes comment alors i believe
dois je t'aime toi je t'aime toi j'ai
ici des 50 elle se tait toi je t'aime je
mets tous ensemble non
et puis bien il ya une autre histoire on
suit à à los angeles
au présente le film cité du cinéma et
bien un journaliste qui ya une scène
dans le huitième jour où ils volent et
les journalistes qui lui dit mais
comment avez vous fait pascal pour voler
dans ce film et débat que j'ai appris
[Applaudissements]
alors aujourd'hui pascal où il vivait
dans un appartement du centre ville de
bruxelles en parfaite autonomie grâce à
l'association huitième jour qui crée des
immeubles adapté est extraordinaire
c'est fait ça évidemment parce qu'en
fait ce qui inquiète et un peu pascal si
dire quand mes parents vont disparaître
comme ma mère va disparaître qu'est-ce
que je qu'est ce que je vais devenir je
venais en foyer l'ex terrain et grâce
ces appartements de l'association du
huitième jour d'un pascal peut vivre
normalement quoi tout à fait d'une façon
tout à fait autonome et on en a trente
maintenant sur quatre maisons c'est bien
et on est occupé à créer une cinquième
maison maintenant pour ceux qui
vieilliront c'est une femme
extraordinaire
ben non je ne bats pour mes enfants
alors pascal aujourd'hui je les 46 ans
vous continuer le cinéma le théâtre la
peinture la gravure et vous dites je ne
suis pas handicapé je suis trisomique
c'est pas la même chose
alors
maintenant
je vais vous expliquer un truc
à partir du 5 avril prochain la france
va passer tnt haute définition
alors si vous êtes équipés d'une box ou
de la fibre vous ne changez rien écoutez
moi bien mais si vous recevez la télé
par une antenne râteau faites le test
vous allez sur la chaîne 7 ou la chaîne
57 et si le logo arte hd apparaît c'est
que vous êtes bien équipé parce que s'il
ne vous n'êtes pas équipé vous allez
avoir un écran noir et il faut acheter
un adaptateur qui s'appelle tnt hd alors
vous aurez toutes les infos sur
l'adresse qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran mais faites gaffe parce que d'un
coup plus de télé écran noir ah oui je
vous préviens
c'est vrai voilà c'est une salut les
terriens votre retour du samedi avec la
ville à l'automne
avec mass caves de la tour
avec finesse et en vie
et
pascal duquenne et m
[Applaudissements]
cette émission en 2006 la semaine
prochaine à 19h10 10la sur canalplus.fr
[Applaudissements]
les corrections de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu